ils avaient des fourmis dans les jambes
il voulait renouer avec la compétition
jusqu'ici les clubs de la région est
organisée quelques petits événements en
interne ce rendez vous marque le premier
gros rassemblement tradition des
calendriers la meeting michel mousson
s'est déroulée sous une forme un peu
particulière situation sanitaire oblige
- d'athlètes - discipline il a fallu
faire des choix
il ya des choses qui ont été écartées
parce qu'on voulait rester sur un format
restreint de compétition toujours dans
cet esprit de distanciation et puis on
l'a on a mis ces épreuves là où on sait
qu'on a des athlètes potentiellement
médaillables ou finaliste au moins en
france reculaient à se projeter dans
l'avenir même s'il est incertain et
surtout penser à la sécurité
un protocole sanitaire a été établi en
lien avec la commission médicale de la
fédération française d'athlétisme
pas de vestiaires sens de circulation
dans le stade désinfection du matériel
bref quelques astuces à trouver
j'ai demandé aux athlètes aux lanceurs
d'amener leurs propres gens qui donc
comme ça ils ont ils peuvent avoir leurs
engins qu'ils ne prêtent pas alors que
le règlement normalement dit quand on
amène son engin on doit pouvoir le
prêter un autre concurrent des
concurrents qui ont accepté les règles
trop contente de pouvoir à nouveau se
mesurer aux autres
déjà qualifié pour les jeux
paralympiques de tokyo gloria est venu
avec son poids son disque et son sourire
ça me fait un grand plaisir parce que
c'est vrai que déjà la première semaine
du confinement n'était pas vraiment bien
et le fait de reprendre les compétitions
enfin les entraînements et les
compétitions bah moi c'est ça ne fait
que du bien en fait c'est c'est ce que
j'attendais vraiment un retour à la
compétition pour tous ces champions en
espérant ne pas être à nouveau mis en
arrêt forcé